avoue gaspar martins
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais pas vous le cacher mais
franchement me retrouver ici à la télé
c'est je trouve ça aussi surréaliste que
bachar el-assad qui reçoit le prix nobel
donc
je suis pas là pour critiquer la télé r
je trouve ça vachement utilise comme un
des seuls endroits où se rencontrent
l'élite et les chômeurs
merci de faire l'élite en tout cas ce
soir quand même 41 mille 300 chômeurs de
plus en un mois
chômeur métiers d'avenir
en même temps ces chiffres seraient
beaucoup plus faible si les nouveaux
chômeurs avait la pudeur ne pas le faire
savoir
c'est quand même dingue hein ce mal
français se vanter de son inactivité
l'arrogance des chômeurs
j'étais venu pour quoi déjà la wii donc
je disais thierry d'autres trucs
s'appelle salut les terriens pas moi
j'vois pas trop en retrait vers ce que
tu leur coût va enfin est-ce qu'ils ont
petit génial à défendre je suis pas
allé martial je trouve ça beaucoup plus
intelligent tu vois il cherche pas à
nous connaître
le preuve d'un génie quoi d'ailleurs se
pouvait continuer ça serait bien nous
pour se faire remarquer qu'est ce qu'on
fait on lance des sons dans l'espace
avec de la musique de mozart ça n'a
aucun intérêt quoi franchement on
devrait plutôt envoyé ce à quoi je
voilà c'est selon
c'est ce que c'est
et veut dans ta chatte
je traduis excusez moi de défendre le
français crise y est rond soit disant
les rebelles de l'été quelle arnaque si
c'était si rebel que ça il aurait fait
la macarena dans une mosquée
elles ont pris deux ans de goulag deux
ans de gaulle la preuve que poutine
s'est assouplie quoi
moi je trouve ça leur fera quand même du
bien que le goulag on trouve
l'inspiration au moulin à 6o jenny s'il
n'était pas allé au goulag il aurait
écrit quoi
l'archipel de ma cuisine font le trou
dont camille martien surtout restez chez
vous ne venez pas parce que ici ça n'a
aucun intérêt que je veux dire
politiquement c'est dur c'est dur la
gauche est au pouvoir quoi les
bolchéviques sont passées
depuis que la gauche s'est passé quoi
moi je me promène jamais tout seul
toujours avec une femme c'est la parité
puis que la gauche est passée cette
femme ne peut pas être de ma couleur
quoi ça s'appelle la diversité
bah c'est pas le seul effet de l'arrivée
de la gauche ça fait fuir les riches
exemple stéphane guillon
après je suis pas là pour dézinguer la
gauche le président enfin c'est un mec
c'est rené coty junior
il a son style et à son style roulant
break
manque plus que l'autocollant j'aime la
plagne coiffant
la pris un break parce qu un corbillard
que c'était un peu trop tôt encore c'est
le truc qui va arriver quoi on lui
reproche de ne pas avoir le même rythme
que sarko quel génie cas sarko quand
même
non mais c'est quand même incroyable ce
type qui arrive à convaincre les
français que l'hystérie c'est un truc
rassurant quoi
je comprends pour les français c'est pas
facile quoi passer d'un coût de 24
heures chrono à louis la brocante
car heureusement qu'il est en couple
avec une fille un peu tendu parce que
pas le couple hollande privé l'eire ça
me fait penser à une éponge de cuisine
plein fouet un côté qui grattent nôtre
qui absorbe
[Musique]
il paraît que vous vous y être pour
quelque chose vous avez de ré ouvrir un
site de rencontre qu'on sache
non mais en tout cas on s'attendait à
tout avec hollande sauf aux feux de
l'amour quoi c'est le truc vraiment
qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'elle lui trouve à
hollande c'est quoi sont déjà yade il ya
des rumeurs il paraît que la côte et
reptilien dragueur comme ça mais j'ai
une copine elle a pris l'ascenseur avec
lui c'est ce qu'il a fait rien
dsk il a vu ça ici dit [ __ ] ce mec
c'est un fou non
alors vous me direz l'opposition existe
web et
l'ump coiffe team fillon contre team
copé la france coule il joue à
intervilles quoi c'est le truc mais
qu'est ce qu'ils ont tous à l'ump de se
réclamer de sarkozy je comprends pas il
est mort parce y est tellement génial
faut le rappeler quoi je sais pas et non
basirat chine fin
mais tout ça c'est de l'anecdote ça
c'est du microcode c'est de la petite
tambouille ça c'est pas nous il ya des
choses beaucoup plus graves en france
beaucoup plus gras audrey pulvar gère
les inrocks
s'imagine c'est comme christine boutin
chez playboy quoi
playmate du mois bernadette soubirous en
string un rêve de gosse
puis à l'insécurité bon ça c'est réglé
maintenant c'est ainsi à manuel valls
sarko qui s'habille chez zara tu vois le
bail a pas de miracle il ya moins de
fric à gauche les gens ils font un peu
moins des fins ils peuvent pas quoi
karachi daf vous êtes une fois d'el
hamma rachid quoi y'a un truc qui
à toutes ces polémiques sur les roms
tout ça ça va ça ça pour des gens du
voyage que de chichi à l'idée d'un
déplacement
et il n'ya pas que ça
économiquement c'est dur quoi c'est la
crise c'est la crise est tellement forte
quand même des braqueurs s'attaque à
emmaüs quoi c'est matt imagine la
réunion préparatoire dégâts demain se
fait quoi secours populaire restos du
coeur ah non pas les restos j'ai assez
de boîtes de cassoulet quoi se faire
autour
quand l'argent c'est un problème bon ça
la france dépense mal son argent c'est
une évidence
bon on n'est pas les seuls le qatar
investit bien dans le psg
le qatar qui investit au psg c'est comme
un gagnant de l'euromillions lui dit
alors vous allez faire quoi être votre
argent à moi je vais acheter de la dette
grecque
toute façon moi le sport ch pour moi
j'ai dû me taper les jeux olympiques
avait rien d'autre alors il ya des
jolies images peut pas dénigrer ses
c'est le truc manaudou et son frère way
[ __ ] moi l'inceste
bailly si on a qui aiment pas fait autre
chose quoi
évidemment après les jeux olympiques on
doit se taper les paralympiques quel
régal
cour des miracles fait de le ps quoi
concours lépine de la béquille
orthopédique enfin je sais pas qui
regarde ça
ça soigne un problème de calendrier quoi
les jeux olympiques et après les
paralympiques chute c'est comme voir une
course de caisses à savon après une
course de formule 1
mais il ya des nouvelles rassurantes il
ya des johnny est vivant
je vais parce que lui c'est un rocker
c'est un iconoclaste c'est un mec choper
une bronchite à saint barth quoi
voilà la malaria au pôle nord
comme un puceau qui décèdent la syphilis
quoi séparé
mais bon peut-être finir sur une
nouvelle un peu optimiste quand on est
positif le prix de l'essence baisse
ouais ouf on va enfin pouvoir s'acheter
un timbre
pas belle la vie et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux